look at presidents who couldn't be
bought
look at presidents who could care less
whether you were going to buy them with
money or not name presidents
historically that couldn't be controlled
by money make presidents that come okay
trump's one of them who else jfk jfk is
another one who else oh teddy roosevelt
dwight eyes not many in the last okay
reagan wait a minute reagan had money
who else okay abraham lincoln you think
lincoln cared about money no what
happened to those four you go go go go
lincoln what happened to him
literal or character assassination yeah
what happened to john f kennedy
what happened to reagan six inches away
what happened to trump they couldn't if
they did what they did to jfk with uh
with uh trump trump would have been
martyr trump would have gone down as the
greatest you know it would have been the
republican you know he would have
replaced reagan if that would have
happened
shocked that there wasn't at least an
attempt on trump i got to be honest i
was shocked i uh how do we know there
weren't yeah i i uh i think to me
i think to me
what's worse though what's worse though
what's worse though there are many
methods of assassination what's worse
characters nothing worse than character
assassination i mean you saw the article
that came up with vanity fair how rudy
giuliani went from a
911 hallowed mayor to 2021 haunted ghoul
if you read that story about rudy
giuliani the way they present him this
guy went from winning the g-man award a
few years ago from fbi in 2015 to all of
a sudden i'm tearing down him too or so
yeah i know i see it i'm just not the
whole story is a long story for me to go
through
giuliani business with china right now
would with
if china wanted to open you wouldn't so
if they said we're going to come in
we're going to make php the i wouldn't
do it
i wouldn't do it you know why i wouldn't
why why why would i ever do something
like that
i'm not a fan of control so what what
leverage do i have over you
let's just say i do that what leverage
do i have over you
what leverage the other day i'm trying
to pick up my uh global entry card from
tsa you know how clear talks to me the
difference between buying a clear card
and tsa you ready clear how are you mr
david good to see you
have you resigned and we'd love to get
your family on the program as well thank
you it's totally fine would you like a
mask oh we'd be more than happy to help
you out you know how tsa
i show up caroline causes this woman
just hung up on me okay i'm driving down
to tsa to get my global entry card why
are you late
why are you so late
what happened do you realize that i said
ma'am this is there's nobody here but
i'm sorry i'm late i said ma'am i'm
looking forward to seeing you in five
years when i renew i will not be here
intentionally to never not ever deal
with somebody like you who is late i
said i'm so sorry so i left 100 bucks
100 bucks government doesn't give you
service you think i want to go in bed
with somebody that represents the
government what are they going to do
they're on my team hell no what team are
they going to be on so i'm surprised
where a lot of these u.s companies want
to do business with china thinking
they're going to be on your team they're
not going to be let me pose you a
question
put yourself
pat now
established has money money's not an
issue
pat 10 years ago just starting out
scraping by yeah i don't maybe you not
saying you but that person don't
disagree maybe by
i don't disagree this is why this is why
i
i'm concerned
if a person who becomes president
doesn't have their own money nor have
they served in the military i have a
hard time with that yeah i think a
president have should their own should
have their own money because you don't
make any desperate moves
and you should have served in the
military those are my two criterias for
me i think because who the hell are you
to tell a military guy what to do do you
realize how disrespectful it is to tell
them miller you don't even know what
life they're living in you want to tell
them what to do
a soldier is going to sit there and say
what the hell are you talking about what
are you talking about like you want to
tell me what my life is like like
imagine if i tell you what it is to be
comedian you guys are going to sit there
and say thomas you don't know what it is
to be comedian i've never been in that
room when comics are talking to it's
like me talking what's the big deal
about stealing jokes you're like what
the hell is the matter with you yeah so
to me you want to be a president
governor whatever
congress senate go forward you want to
be president you have to have your own
money established your own money and
number two you have to have certain
millionaires well look at trump he had
his own money but he didn't serve in the
military so
i'm not that's not i'm just asking yeah
and he's getting there telling generals
what to do i'm sorry there's a
difference you got if you don't have it
you can't talk to them as if you know
their world do you know the only
president to have a family member serve
in the military in the last 50 years
bush
no family
a kid like a kid one of their kids is is
biden
no no i'm talking about them them no i
know i get it i i'm saying that but
you're saying you have no authority to
tell a general trust but you do not
let me tell you military is a very
emotional yeah these guys are talking
about mental uh
you know health and all this stuff by
the way in the military like simone
biles can take a break and go become a
hero for mental health and what she did
she has a choice to do that of course
you can't do that in war
you you cannot do that when you're under
that pressure you cannot do that when
you're firing lines you don't have the
luxury to say hey guys please stop
shooting guys please
i have a headache i'm getting i'm
getting an attack anxiety
let's please stop i'm gonna take a break
this is too much for me please i'm
asking you stop shooting okay i'm gonna
get up it's like you know how you do a
paint gun and guy gets up and walks out
guys guys guys
[Laughter]
so so for a person to act like they
understand the military or for a person
who doesn't have money
for a person who doesn't have money to
be a president you scare me yeah let me
let me give you a different perspective
one of the things when we when we hire
c-suite executives you know what i like
to hear from c suite executives i'll
tell you one of the guys who
expected a job here's how he recruited
himself look at the way he did it i
loved his interview one of my favorites
the way he did it he says uh i just want
you to know i have a lot of different
options right now
for jobs because i'm very good at what i
do and you can call my references of the
last 20 years and you will see what they
say i work half days these are the kind
of hours i work i'm going to be here at
this time i'm going to be at this time
and my schedule works this way but i
want you and i've had a lot of different
exits so financially i don't need salary
i don't care what you pay me salary wise
you need to pay me a decent salary for
what the market tells me but i don't
want to be the highest paid salary guys
my interest is in equity i want you to
give me equity and give me a lot of
equity because that's what i want to
build i want to help build a company
because i've already had multiple
seven-figure exits i have cash i have
money i don't need to worry about what i
need to do take care of my family for
the rest of my life
but i'm only here because the equity
do you know
i
want him in leadership position because
he will never make a desperate move nor
will he ever give me feedback because
he's worried about finances now flip it
i had another guy that came for a job
interview
a few years ago i'm doing the interview
with them this is one of the reasons why
i was scared about the haircut i was
getting yesterday
this is another interview i'm doing for
job this guy's also applying for c-suite
job but this is five years ago six years
ago
so he comes in and the interview goes
resume decorated decorated resume and he
goes through it i want to be the cmo and
i want to do this i'm going to say no
problem let's go through the interview
so all of a sudden in the interview okay
first ten minutes impressive second ten
minutes impressive third ten minutes he
just says man i gotta let you know
what's been happening with me this is my
second divorce and i just went through
this and i have to pay this much money
and i'm back on the rent if you can just
pay in advance of twenty thousand
dollars for me to be able to do this and
for me to be able to do that and while
i'm moving this if you can throw another
ten thousand dollars in a minute it'll
be so amazing because of where i'm at
you know what i sat there and i thought
about i'm like
oh i got to be careful with this why
because
because you and by the way there's
difference all of us have been in a
desperate position before but not
this is not even a talent thing i don't
worry about talent this is an executive
position
an this is very different with talent
talent is a different story an executive
position where you have to lead people
you can't be stressed out about money
so
i want to make sure household is good i
want to make sure finances are good i
want to make sure you've had the moral
authority to tell other people what to
do so you want to be a president i would
if i was obviously i'm not the one
that's making the guidelines here for me
if you want to be a president i think
you got to have a net worth of
you got to have your wife your kids
covered your future retirement covered
if you got minimum 10 million dollars 20
million okay great that's that's fine
but if you're in and you're only worth a
couple hundred thousand dollars you're
gonna do side deals for money because
you've never tasted money before
you've never tasted money before what if
you've made these 10 20 million dollars
in politics no i don't like that yeah i
don't like that because to me
you again kai
so to me there's two things that you
will never relate to two things that you
will never relate to so for example
let's put the one thing that men will
never understand what is what is the one
thing a baby we will never
understand what it is to have a baby
ever i've seen my wife we
what she goes through with the baby we
are never gonna understand that pain
okay that they go through now
so let's set that aside that's on the
pinnacle position for me at the top so
let's set that part aside we're never
going to know no matter what we ever do
you're never going to know it so now
let's go to the other side a woman who
was a woman worth a half a billion she
said hey man can i tell you guys
something the closest thing you'll ever
know about what it is to raise a baby
and have a baby is to start a company
and you're the founder only founders
will know the closest thing to the pain
we go through having a baby okay
if a politician has never ran a business
where he put his money on the line how
the hell do you know what it is to be a
small business owner you don't know what
it is to be a small but you don't even
know how scary it is you don't know what
it is to be a tax by the way when i was
going through anxiety attacks in 2013
2014 i couldn't tell the bank to stop
asking for payments i couldn't tell my
guy that i'm a release the two million
dollar contract on the office building
to give me six months to pay rent i
couldn't tell the guys hey please guys
don't put this i couldn't tell my
competitors stop trying to approach some
of my guys i couldn't tell my carriers
hey please be a little bit nicer to us
right now because i'm going through
mental and anxiety i couldn't tell
anybody anything
founders don't have that ability should
you be able to should you be able to
call timeout no you you it's like the
war analogy it's not about yes you
should be able to but should your
competitors stop taking business from
you no
you should be able to do it but you
should also realize that you're going to
lose if you do that yes no one's going
to stop competing the market's not going
to stop competing in this kind of a
society so you have a little bit of a
hard time
when somebody becomes a president who
one hasn't made the money and two you've
never served ah what moral authority
does it give you to tell us what to do
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]